[Musik]
im zuge der scheitelhöhe 2009 10
erstmals alle selbstständig
strukturierten tiroler milizverbände und
polizeieinheiten es sind dies das
jägerbataillon tirol gibt der mehr
komponiert tirol die jäger company
oberland die tiroler force provider züge
sowie die wache organisation des
militärkommandos tirol
ich bin bei der miliz weil ich der
überzeugung bin dass sie für die
aufrechterhaltung der militärischen
landesverteidigung notwendig ist und
dazu möchte ich meinen beitrag leisten
meine motivation bei der miliz zu sein
ist es neben einem zivilen beruf mich
auch militärisch weiter fortbilden zu
können um eine funktion als zugs command
beim jägerbataillon tirol nachzukommen
bei der miliz weil die damals mit kraft
dass sie unterstützung alle grenzen
brauchen und werkzeug das ganz kurz
andere menschen in der
landesverteidigung zu helfen ich bin
gerne bei der miliz um einen beitrag zu
schutz und hilfe in unserem land zu
geben und eine übung wie diese zum
schutz kritischer infrastruktur ist ein
wirklich gutes beispiel für mich
[Musik]
bis jetzt bin ich mit dem übungslauf
sehr zufrieden wir haben ganz viel
erfahrungen sammeln können ganz viel
lernen können wir festgestellt dass die
ambition der übungsanlage sehr
herausfordernd war die leute wirklich in
grenzbereiche gebracht hat aber nachdem
sie bewältigt
freuen sie sich über den erfolg